a popular dating app has been found to
have discriminated against some of its
older users tinder lets people find
potential matches by swiping their phone
a swipe right means you're interested in
a swipe left means you're not anyone can
use the free option but the app
introduced a premium service in 2015
called tinder Plus which has extra
features and it starts at $9.99 for
users younger than 30 but people 30 and
over are charged $19.99 for the same
service an appellate court in California
this week ruled tenders price structure
is discriminatory CBS News legal analyst
Ricky cleamen is here good morning good
morning number one I didn't know people
over the thirty are using the tinder app
but it's explaining illegal well I
suppose we might at this table all be
surprised about how many people over the
age of 30 are using it but what the
California appeals court says is clear
and simple they say this is
discrimination in pricing based on age
and why is that illegal in California
California is the broadest disc
anti-discrimination is the statute and
what it says is this you can't change
her age your age is you it's the same as
a sexual orientation or your gender or
your race and the assumption that you
make more money than someone under 30
and that therefore you have more ability
to pay is too big an assumption it's too
much of a personal characteristic that
is generalized because there are people
who are exceptions to the rule so what
does tinder say in response to well Tim
Dewar actually had a very good argument
you have to remember that tinder won in
the trial court on the paperwork this
was in essence of motion to dismiss that
the lawyers call a demurrer that in the
trial court in their wins Y becomes
hizzoner says look we did market based
research we have a legitimate basis to
say that there is a reason that people
have more disposable income after the
age of 30 and the trial court agreed the
appellate court said no you're
absolutely wrong under the Unruh Act
there's companies like Spotify and Hulu
they offered
counts for four younger customers so
what's the but it's fascinating
remember this ruling is only right now
in California it's not all over the
United States but it is something to
look at you can have obviously student
discounts you can have tiered pricing
like we all looked at perhaps our cable
systems you could have a bronze silver
or gold members you pay more at early
bird specials senior citizens and get to
go to the movies for less money senior
citizens and children there are laws
that protect them we want to give our
seniors discounts and we do assume they
have less disposable income those
younger now I'm gonna have to change
their pricing structure now if tinder
stays right where this case is tinder
must change his pricing structure as
regarding people over 30 tinder however
can appeal to the highest court in
California and there is contrary case
law which echoes Lord NORs question
about health clubs so they probably
would be wise to appeal ultimately this
is a case where this court was very firm
and it's based in the law you have to
see that if you don't have an overriding
public policy like a senior or a child
or a student we want to encourage
education then you may be out of luck
well to my knowledge nobody at this
table is use tinder but I think it's
good to know for other people that do
they say don't use tinder Dale I've been
married for 23 years that's why I was
just curious Ricky Cleavon always good
to have you at the table thank you